let's now try to convert a number from
the decimal system to the hexadecimal
system
so let's say we want to convert the
number 2000
in or this is it written in decimal form
let's say we want to write it in
hexadecimal form and like always i
encourage you to pause this video and
try to work through it on your own
so the key here is to break this down
into powers of multiples of powers of
16. so let's just write down our powers
of 16 here so 16 to the zero power is
one 16 to the first power is 16
16 squared is
256. 16 to the third power is
4096. so that's already we've gotten
more than large enough and let's start
decomposing
so what's the largest power of 16 that
goes into that that is less than or
equal to 2000
well it's going to be 256 and how many
times does 256 go into 2000 well i'll
get a calculator out for that
so
2000
minus oh sorry it's divided by i should
say i want to figure out how many times
256 goes into it
divided by 256 is so it goes seven times
plus a little bit so it's going to be
left over so 2000
minus 7 times
256
is equal to you're gonna have 208 left
over so let me write that it's going to
be 7 times 256
7
times 256
plus
plus 208 left over plus 208 left over
now let's see if we can decompose 208
into powers of 16 what's the largest
power of 16 that is less than or equal
to this well it's just going to be 16.
so how many 16s go into 208
so 208 i'll just take that divided by
16.
13 exactly 13 we lucked out so this is
exactly 13 times 16. so let's just write
that
this right over here
is exactly 13 times
16.
and so now we have broken this down into
powers of we have broken this down to
multiples of powers of 16. now we're
ready to write it in hexadecimal and we
just have to remind ourselves about the
place value
so this right over here this is going to
be the ones place
then we're gonna have the sixteens place
and then we're gonna have the
256's place
256's place
and we know how many 256's we have we
have seven 250 sixes
we have zero ones
we have zero ones and how many sixteens
do we have well we have 13 16. well
what's the digit for 13 and we can just
remind ourselves
that we could just remind ourselves that
we have obviously 0 through 9 and then
we have a
is equal to 10
b is equal to 11
c is equal to 12
d is equal to 13 and of course e is
equal to 14 and f is equal to 15. but we
care about 13 we have 13
16s we have 13 16. so we put a d right
over here so the number 7do and
hexadecimal so let me write this down
this is interesting so 2000
in decimal form that's when it's in
decimal form is equal to
7
d o
when it is written in hexadecimal
form hope you found that interesting